seis meses después del inicio de la
pandemia la vida retoma en venecia los
gondoleros vuelven a navegar en los
canales y a pocos kilómetros del centro
de la ciudad el nido una de las islas
del archipiélago de la laguna de venecia
se transforma en el epicentro mundial de
la cultura ya que aquí se inaugura la
mostra el festival internacional de cine
de venecia
evento que representa este es un evento
muy muy importante para esta ciudad y
para el cine en general el virus no debe
interrumpir el arte ni la cultura ni a
las personas para en el arte de la
cultura en el personal este año 18
películas todos los estrenos mundiales
compiten por el león de oro en la
sección oficial entre ellas una película
latinoamericana bautizada nuevo orden
dirigida por el mexicano michel franco
es tema central de la película es
la brecha que hay entre muchísimos
millones de pobres y muy poca gente que
tiene una acumulación de riqueza
tremenda eso me parece la fórmula para
el desastre el cine de américa latina
también estará presente en las secciones
paralelas del festival con cintas de
colombia argentina y brasil para el
género de latinoamericano estas
vidrieras del cine que son los
festivales son muy importantes porque
aparte siempre de los nombres conocidos
que pueden ser cotizarse en el mercado
están los nuevos están los que no tienen
un respaldo de trama más que de las
instituciones oficiales si las tienen
entonces es aquí donde pueden darse a
conocer para evitar las hembra mentos el
público no tendrá acceso al tapete rojo
algo que decepciona a algunos habitantes
es una edición triste este año no se
puede ni siquiera acercar al tapete rojo
los organizadores de este festival
esperan hacer renacer la industria
cinematográfica gracias a este evento
que se concluirá el próximo 12 de
septiembre